from usmansonko's home region in the far
south
to the capital dakar his followers have
taken their demands to the streets of
senegal
all senegalese people expressed their
dissatisfaction with the regime he is
the dictator president makisel
we are fighting for freedom for justice
and also for the development of senegal
protesters faced off against riot police
at the tear gas canisters flu
several people have already died in six
days of protests
triggered by sanko's arrest
the victims must not have been in vain
so that this never happens again in
senegal
we must maintain this mobilization it
must be even bigger
but it must be peaceful
senegal usually a beacon of stability in
west africa
has been rocked by its worst violence in
years
i call for calm and peace
all together let's silence our
bitterness and avoid the logic of
confrontation
which leads to the worst
president sull has been in power since
2012
political pressure on him is growing
fueled by
allegations that any challenges are
subject to political hit
jobs the opposition fears he may try for
a third term
beyond the two-term limit in the
constitution
the people demanded that in 2024 he will
pack his bags and he will leave
for now sanko seems willing to bide his
time till the next poll in 2024
as the protests swell his followers may
not
want to wait that long
i'm now joined by journalist samba bhaji
he's the editor of africa check
in their dakar bureau welcome to the
program samba
now usman songko is still calling for
mass protests across the country are
these
likely to continue now that he's been
released from police custody
yes really sanko called for mass protest
but
uh uh peacefully so uh and this
sunk was called uh it was a call already
made on saturday by a group of political
parties
and citizen movement for three days of
demonstrations
through the country on monday tuesday
and wednesday
and yes the release of sanko seems to
ease the tension
especially since the president makissa
also made a speech on monday
on monday evening also calling for calm
and
announcing an easing of the curfew uh
that was imposed in
the context of the struggle against kobe
19. all of this could
help ease the tension but yes the the
demonstration
will continue but uh i i think that
it will be uh uh it
won't be in the same level as there was
uh
last days okay just looking at
usmansonko
as a politician he came third in the
elections
uh several other opposition candidates
um who contested against the president
have since
joined the government of national unity
is there any chance of sunko being
co-opted or
or does he pose a genuine threat
um i think there is no chance that sanko
will be corrupted uh to
join the the makissa regime and because
sanko is now in a position of uh being
the number one
opponent uh to to to makissa's resume
and uh he's a truly a threat to the
ruling establishment
as he's calling to a shift in the way
politics is done in in the country since
the independence
is also gathering more and more
support from people coming from
different political lines
you can have former leftist nationalist
and paraphernalicalist and also
songko and his allies also plead for
a redefinition of relations with the
former colonial power
of france and this is uh badly seen by
the establishment and
and and his political uh line
uh he is his political line is seen as a
new uh a new wave uh in the country so
yes funko is seen as a threat
to to make sure regime right and senegal
has long been seen as one of
west africa's more stable democracies
have these recent
events damage that status
i will not say that i do not say that
the recent events have
damaged these status it is true that
senegal
has always been a stable democracy
but in recent years many democratic
gains has been
lost and what i think is that
these recent events are a kind of an
expression of
fed up and that perhaps they they will
allow the the leaders the government to
remember that it is absolutely necessary
to
preserve the senegalese democracy okay
somebody in dakar um speaking to us
there
thank you very much for bringing us up
to speed